tanks ROP in battlefield 1 no surprise
there despite being a closed alpha build
they're still allowed we can take away
from these hunks of metal so here is an
early guide to understanding each of the
vehicles and their best practices on the
battlefield one before we take a look at
each of the four vehicles let's go
through some of the general basics first
off when you spawn in a vehicle's driver
position you take on the tank class it's
imperative you do so because it grants
you the ability to repair the burden of
repairing is you can't be taking any
damage and it also makes your tank in
operable which sucks yet if your engine
or tracks are disabled you're sitting
duck so you might as well do so luckily
all these tanks are equipped with smoke
or poison gas so do your best to save it
at the ready hitting it will mask your
tank heightening your odds of getting
one repair counter in allowing you to
bounce out and live to fight another day
even if your engine and tracks are
intact and you're in a sticky situation
hit smoke or gas and throw it in reverse
be that nifty ninja and keep them
guessing don't forget the tank class is
also packing an anti-tank grenade so if
you're doomed and forced to flee get
back at them and Chuck a couple of these
because chances are you're already dead
all tanks have five rounds at the ready
yet they are a pain to reload in which
case always be reloading always when
you're down to that last round your fire
rate drops significantly no bueno and
don't forget all tanks have a secondary
shotgun cannon for infantry you can drop
med packs at capture points Oh in the
class also gives you a hammer however it
currently repairs at two percent
increments making it not very useful you
are better off using it as a weapon
touching back on repairing this mechanic
is actually ingrained with how tank
tactics operate this system transpires
into a fight flight or fix dynamic and
it actually varies on each vehicle
essentially what taint you're in and
what tank you're matched against will
completely change your tactics and
that's our segue into dissecting each
tank
unfortunately this armored car is not a
tank so let's just get this out of the
way the cars health is so low you can
take damage from practically every
weapon on the field it's the only
vehicle that spawns on the map making it
prime for quick captures on flags you're
really actually a fast-moving spawn so
don't stop moving the land ship is a
three-seater and it's the most powerful
tank because of these two cannon
positions and there lies the problem if
you don't have at least one of these
seats filled you're outmatched all you
have is a forward firing machine gun
with a limited view so squad up or spam
that get in chat and make yourself
enticing because man if you're a full
boat you can wreck shop as the driver
it's your goal to give your cannon ops
love consider this approach against an
enemy tank show your first can in the
target once he fires quickly whip your
second can inside around if done right
you out match the enemy's fire rate
oddly enough the heavy tank is actually
the fastest tank in the lot its top
speed doesn't just make it great for
capturing midpoint flags but for laying
down up to three landmines consider
placing these mines around capture
points and town crossroads this giant
toaster has five gunner positions but
with the patience of most teammates
chances are two of the seats will be
filled at one time fortunately armor is
protecting its tracks so it's really got
no weak spots so when you're in control
don't bow down at anyone if you're at
sixty percent health don't think an
incoming light tank has the upper hand
you don't need to repair yet just keep
hammering until you see yellow or red
text then repair away lastly and
certainly not least the light tank oddly
enough it's the slowest land vehicle but
all you really need is that 360 degree
turret you are a one-man show flanker
think outside the box and always be
moving sure your cannon isn't as
powerful as a heavy tank that's fine
circle him while firing once that
toasters plug is disabled he's all yours
you
for land chips it's a different story
attempt to position yourself to its
front or back keep in mind your tracks
are your weak point so attack from
straight on whenever possible and lastly
yes your poison gas is great for masking
getaways but it's also poison if you got
campers hiding in a capture point give
them a reason to leave and there you
have it a first look at ground vehicles
and battlefield one I hope you learned
something today and if you have any
pointers yourself put them in the
comments section or send them my way on
twitter be sure to subscribe for more
valve field1 content down the road and
as always thanks for watching